Aaron is one of the most enduring and
useful kinds of IDs in mathematics right
it just pops up everywhere you know so
it's very accessible right like in fact
the first time that you learn about like
something as simple as multiplication is
when you first go from adding and you'll
learn your times tables like x is a
thing that you can do okay we learn it
in terms of area so for example
establishing the fact that 3 times 5 is
the same as 5 times 3 is very easy
established through area right because
you take a shape which is 3 by 5 and
then all you need to do is turn it on
its side and you have 5 times 3 but it's
the same shape right so error is
something we begin with very very early
on and yet if you've got this graph as
little parabola or not despite its
simplicity it's sort of disguises hide
these very very deep questions example
okay we know how to find the area of
rectangles what other kinds of shapes do
we know how to find the area of example
what else in fact you can work out the
area of any polygon if you like so let's
cut straight edges and you can work out
so happy with this idea and we spend a
long time trying to work this out we
even develop you know really fancy
sophisticated ways of working out some
these different areas okay
and yet if you come to like almost one
of the most simple curves that we know
how to draw right in fact by the
definition about the general what are
the people say curves like this is the
simplest curve that you can draw okay
like you can draw y equals x but it's
not curvy okay now to try to work out
the area underneath this curve take for
example it's pretty soon I'll put in
some lines in here if I put in a
boundary like that and say okay look
he's a shape under here
what's its area okay how big is that
thing if you know where you start and
where you end suppose that's something
right and I'm called to or something
like that how big is the shaded area
it's an immensely simple shape
amidst the support however it defies all
of this understanding we already have
developed on area there's the polygon
that you can fit in there because of the
nature of this treatment now that's
going to be exactly equal to this area
there's not even like any combination of
circles or semi circles or sectors then
you can try and like fit the curves and
so that it's like nice and exact you
can't get there such a simple question
okay so riemann was this mathematician
german guy double and worth writing his
name who saw this this is an interesting
problem okay we want to try and tackle
this problem so he said look okay
classic mathematical technique if you
can't work out a problem as it is stated
what should you is you try and simplify
the problem and see if you can work out
well can I work out an answer to a
simpler version of this and maybe I can
kind of like import that understanding
forward okay
so for instance I've you've got all
these shapes of a here that we know how
to work out the area Rim was really
smart he said you know what I can be try
and approximate this area we'd like
versions of those so he was the first
way he did it draw some vertical lines
in for me so that we can divide this
interval let's divide it maybe into four
if you have okay and then if you're Hana
these two
Bremen said or each of those those four
pieces that I've got one two three four
I'd still don't know what each of those
is because there's sort of that curvy
bit okay but I can approximate them with
shapes that I know how to work out okay
so the first way you did this and we're
going to one we're gonna copy this over
as well he said look I'm gonna draw some
rectangles in here we draw some
rectangles for instance I got her a
rectangle okay now if I shade these in
like so there is actually even though
I've only drawn three rectangles in
there's actually a fourth one right
fourth one yeah it just doesn't have any
height because I'm I'm on the ground
there these four rectangles the area
that I loft on the green area the curvy
area
it clearly is going to be greater than
this area do you agree with that it's
it's just a but it's always about right
so it's like I'm missing these little
gaps okay
so that'll get close but I can be even
smarter and I can say see these same
subdivisions that gave us four I've got
rectangles underneath the curve I can
also put some rectangles in above the
curve like this
okay now these are I'm not going to
color than me because it will make my
diagram too busy
we've got enough colors as you probably
can but the areas of those four red
dotted rectangles okay can you see they
always above the curve always above
always a bar boys a bar so the actual
area I want right it's going to be less
than the red dotted area and it's going
to be more than well I call it beyond
the blue shaded area those blue
rectangles so riemann said hey this is
really good because even though i don't
have it exact i can pin down this area
within some actual numbers because well
they are rectangles I can deal with
rectangles okay now here is a crucial
step where we're going to dip it now
from where say an engineer or even to
some extent a scientist would stop if I
can know that the area is between these
two values
right draw a new trouble over here next
to this right or a new problem the same
one y equals x squared if I know it's
between these two values all I need to
do is to get these obsessions in area is
to get these two areas the blue one and
the red one to get them really really
close together okay to get the
rectangles underneath and the rectangles
the red rectangles above to get those
values very very close okay now Raymond
said okay I know exactly how to do this
right instead of dividing this area for
instance into four slices what if we
divided it into more right like say we
divide it up into four let's divided up
let's double it so there's my four and
now if I have every one of those
millions without one now when I draw my
rectangles okay
in fact it's actually important that we
draw the rectangles you've got the first
one then the second one and so on what I
want you to pay very close attention to
years how about look at those gaps the
difference between the actual area that
I want the curved area and all of these
rectangles that I'm now adding into this
diagram do you see that these gaps have
gotten smaller do you notice that these
caps here are pretty huge you can see
them very obviously and more gaps but
they're all smaller to all the two
little triangles and exactly the same
way when I put in the red rectangle to
go over the top of these guys like so
the blue area underestimates the area
under the curve and the red area over
estimates the area under the curve but
the overestimation in the
underestimation are now smaller right so
these two numbers are going to get
closer to each other now an engineer
would say look I just need this to be
close enough close enough my people say
oh yeah you know I know
50 million billion whatever decimals
apply all right
anyways we'll only ever use about six
about six right one two three four five
six at that point there that's insane
accuracy enough to do any like building
a bridge you're dealing with that's just
fine if you want make a circle after how
many circles in your designer or an
engineer would need to say is the case
long as I can get close enough as long
as I can get these numbers close enough
together I'm happy right I've got
something that's accurate enough for me
to work with okay but in this classroom
we're not in canoes
mathematicians I'm never satisfied with
close enough we say can we get this
exactly okay so in order to do that we
need a bell language to describe